-Performing "On My Mama"
from her album "Jaguar II,"
give it up for Victoria Monét!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-"Fallon."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm Victoria Monét.
And this is for my mama.
♪♪
-♪ They say,
"She get it from her mama" ♪
♪ I'mma say,
"You got it right" ♪
♪ Body rude, it's unpolite ♪
♪ Done being the humble type ♪
♪ Tell me, is you down? ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm tryna
go up tonight ♪
♪ Hoes and hoochies
left and right ♪
♪ I just wanna live in
a fantasy ♪
♪ I think we deserve it,
right? ♪
♪ Top all the memories ♪
♪ I've ever made in my life ♪
♪ Permanent ecstasy ♪
♪ The ladies is pimps tonight ♪
♪ Living inside a dream ♪
♪ Let's lay where
the lovers lie ♪
♪ I put that on my own mama ♪
♪ On my hood ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look good ♪
♪ You can't touch my bag ♪
♪ Wish you could ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look too good ♪
♪ Put that on my own mama ♪
♪ On my hood ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look good ♪
♪ You can't touch my bag ♪
♪ Wish you could ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look too good ♪
-♪ On my mama ♪
♪ On my hood ♪
♪ I look fly, yeah ♪
♪ I look good ♪
♪ Touch my swag ♪
♪ Wish you could ♪
♪ I look fly, yeah ♪
♪ I look good, good, good ♪
-♪ I'm so deep in my bag ♪
♪ Like a grandma wit'
a peppermint ♪
♪ They say,
"Ooh, she smell good" ♪
♪ That's just 'cause
I'm heaven-sent ♪
♪ Sex game go ♪
-♪ Stupid ♪
-♪ Snappin' like a ♪
-♪ Toothpick ♪
♪ Man, to tell the truth ♪
♪ Your opinion is irrelevant,
but I ♪
♪ I know you think I'm fine ♪
♪ Might be too fine to hit it
from behind ♪
♪ Reflection in the mirror,
don't decline ♪
♪ I can't even lie, lie, lie ♪
♪ I put that on my own mama ♪
♪ On my hood ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look good ♪
♪ You can't touch my bag ♪
♪ Wish you could ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look too good ♪
♪ Put that on my own mama ♪
♪ On my hood ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look good ♪
♪ You can't touch my bag ♪
♪ Wish you could ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look too good ♪
-♪ On my mama ♪
-Hey! Hey!
-♪ On my hood ♪
♪ I look fly, yeah ♪
♪ I look good ♪
♪ Touch my swag ♪
-♪ Touch my swag ♪
-♪ Wish you could ♪
♪ I look fly, yeah ♪
-♪ Hey ♪
-♪ I look good, good, good ♪
♪ On my mama ♪
-♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look good ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ I look fly ♪
♪ I look too good ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]